je tenais absolument à remettre le césar
du meilleur décor cette année parce que
je voulais être le premier dans cette
cérémonie à qui ça tient à coeur de
remettre le césar du meilleur décor
bonsoir je préfère prévenir tout de
suite je suis peut-être que non mais je
préfère le dire je sais pas il est
possible que mon intervention soit un
petit peu islamo gauchiste ouais je
préfère le dire dès le départ c'est pas
trop ça veut dire et j'ai certainement
dire des choses avec lesquelles vous
n'êtes pas d'accord et ça a priori
islamo gauchiste voilà alors j'ai pas
parlé de l'année dernière ne vous
inquiétez pas je suis pas venu pour ça
mais sachez quand même que si vous
n'êtes que 100 dans une salle de 2000
cette année ça n'a rien à voir avec le
co vidant non c'est que cette année on
n'a gardé que ce dont on est sûr qu'ils
n'auront jamais un balances ton port il
reste que vous voilà
ouais bien tenté maintenant il faut que
vous sachiez moi je suis venu pour
remettre ce césar il faut pas que vous
ayez de doute sur ce qui va se passer ce
soir c'est possible que j'ai un truc que
j'ai pas de prompteur mais tout va très
bien se trouver leur passé est-ce que
vous avez un texte en coulisses et que
je peux vous aider non non je suis un
professionnel je le fais très bien non
oui oui on complique est d'accord alors
soit on laisse les nommer vous reparler
ensuite on va pas lancer les nommés
parce que je connais tout à fait la
suite de tête
alors oui ne vous inquiétez pas le
cinéma ça n'est pas nécessaire voilà ce
que je hais ce que c'était bien de
retrouver le tennis c'est ça le cinéma
ce n'est pas nécessaire enlevez vous ce
que ce poids des épaules
on les verra plus tard les films c'est
pas grave mais puisque je sens que
l'année un peu compliqué pour vous c'est
très particulier parce que c'est délicat
parce que c'est compliqué pour vous mais
vous avez encore trop d'argent pour
pouvoir vous plaindre c'est un peu
délicat
ouais là vous êtes timide encore un
petit peu vous trouver des subterfuges
dit à faut penser aux techniciens vous
êtes un petit peu un mais vous inquiétez
pas le cinéma ce n'est pas nécessaire
mais en soi c'est beau parce que c'est à
dire qu'on peut rater un film c'est pas
grave de le rater un film alors après
sans mauvais jeu de mots on ne peut pas
faire un film raté encore faire un film
raté ça peut arriver et ça on peut
toujours leur acheter sur amazon prime
donc c'est pas grave en soi il faut
rester positif
ok alors moi j'ai pas fait de cinéma ça
qu'on ne connaissait pas juste été dans
tout simplement noir ce comme c'est dit
ouais ça lui est ce que comme c'est dit
dans le titre
comme c'est dit dans le titre je n'avais
pas le choix
et ouais il y avait que deux noirs qui
n'était pas dedans c'est thomas n'gijol
et de données ngijol parce que le
jean pascal a dit le réalisateur voulait
que le film ait du succès et c'est pas
moi c'est vrai les aides et dieudonné
parce que jean pascal a dit le
réalisateur voulait que le film existe
ce qu'il est engagé mais je suis quand
même
alors ce qu'elle a voulu dire c'est ce
que je veux vous dire ce soir avec tout
ça aïssa maïga dernière n'a pas été
entendu ce que la diversité dans le
cinéma la discrimination dans le cinéma
en france comme partout ailleurs c'est
comme les agressions sexuelles c'est pas
parce que on n'en parle plus
qu'on le voit plus que ça veut dire
qu'il y en a moins donc il faut arrêter
avec omar sy arrêté avec omar sy puisque
même pour omar sy c'est pas facile
d'accord vraiment sachez qu'au casting
d'un intouchable dès le début ils
savaient qu'ils voulaient un noir ils
ont quand même hésité entre omar et fred
donc il faut savoir il faut savoir tout
ça et omar sy là et vient de faire la
série la plus vue en france de tous les
temps première aux états unis et encore
des gens en france pour dire ouais je
suis pas je trouve pas ça réaliste ouais
c'est pas réaliste il ya un noir en
france qui vole et je n'arrête pas
immédiatement le noir ouais c'est pas
réaliste one
[Applaudissements]